SCP-106 is like something out of a night terror.
That gray, rotting flesh, those wide, empty
eyes like those of a shark, the relentless
corrosion and decay that follows him everywhere.
But what if I told you that, beneath that
horrifying exterior, was a heartbreaking,
tragic backstory?
Some of our more eagle-eyed viewers know that
SCP-106 has a wide variety of potential origin
stories, different events that may have led
to the Old Man we all know and fear today.
So, this is just one of several hypothetical
backstories.
With that little caveat out of the way, it's
time to see if we can bring a tear to your
eye with the tragic tale of SCP-106.
Back in the year 2000, Dr. Robert Scranton
and his wife, Dr. Anna Lang, were Head Researchers
at Site-120.
The two of them shared a lot of things: a
home, a life, a shared love of Bon Jovi songs,
but one of the things they had in common was
a passion for experimental research.
The two worked together to develop a device
called the "Lang-Scranton Stabilizer", which
was an early prototype of the Reality Anchors
used by the SCP Foundation to this day.
During a round of routine tests, an earthquake
unexpectedly struck Site-120.
Dr. Scranton was working in Reality Lab A
when the ground beneath him began to rumble.
The LSS shook from the activity, components
sliding out of place or breaking off altogether.
By the time guards, and Dr. Lang, arrived
to inspect the scene, both Dr. Scranton and
the LSS Control Panel were gone.
Upon his disappearance, Dr. Scranton was initially
presumed dead.
However, five years, eleven months, and 21
days later, his whereabouts became clear.
On December 23, 2005, the LSS Control Panel
reappeared in Site-120's Reality Lab A. It
was covered in unknown organic matter, and
reeked of vomit, blood, and death.
As Dr. Anna Lang waded into the area, against
the warnings of her colleagues, she was overwhelmed
with grief and horror.
She choked back tears as she accessed the
control panel, retrieving the audio files
left there, and realized that Dr. Scranton
had been keeping a log of his time in whatever
place the disaster had sent him.
The husband she had lost had, in a way, come
back to her, but she could not see him.
She could hear his voice, but where was he?
There was so much blood, so much unidentified
organic matter.
It looked like something had exploded onto
the control panel, and she didn't want to
think about what, or who, that could have
been.
As Robert's wedding ring fell to the floor,
landing in the muck, the emotional strain
became too much for Dr. Lang.
She collapsed onto the ground, hitting her
head on the pavement.
Dr. Lang survived her fall, left only with
a tender spot on her skull, and a wealth of
questions she was almost too afraid to answer.
But she had to find out, with answers at her
fingertips, she had to know what had become
of her dear Robert.
So, with the help of the other Site-120 Researchers,
who promised to step in when it became too
painful, Dr. Lang began to go through the
audio archives left behind by her lost love
in the years since he had vanished.
For the first eight days, Dr. Scranton didn't
speak.
At least, not in any recognizable words.
He hyperventilated, he muttered to himself,
he sobbed, he screamed with pure rage and
despair, but he didn't say a word.
He paced around the new space, clawing for
a way out, throwing his shoulder against any
hard surface he could in an attempt to bust
open a door, but he was trapped.
On his eleventh day in the pocket dimension
outside of any world he knew, Dr. Scranton
began to speak.
He reminded himself, reminded anyone who might
some day listen, who he was: Robert Scranton.
Age 39.
Born September 19, 1961.
Favorite color, blue.
Favorite song, "Living on a Prayer."
Wife, Anna.
Every day, he repeated these simple truths,
seeking comfort in his memories of Anna and
the life they once shared.
Her green eyes, their wedding day, her dressed
in white shoving a piece of cake into his
face with a giddy laugh and a sparkle in her
eye.
He hoped that she was okay, that she had managed
to escape the chaos with her life, that she
had been spared a similar fate.
He repeated her nickname, the password he
had set for the control panel: "Anna bo banna."
At this point, he realized that the machine
was still recording.
He called out for help, desperate to see if
anyone could hear him.
"Is anyone there?!
Hello?
Anyone?
ANYONE?!"
But of course, there was no answer.
"Why the hell is this thing even working,
it can't be working."
He mused.
"What the hell?!"
He couldn't see anything, not the switches
or the knobs, only the blinking of the red
"recording" light.
He was growing hungrier and thirstier by the
day, and though he knew he should be dead
from dehydration by now, somehow he wasn't.
He was still alive.
Soon, he found the controls, and determined
he had been trapped in this place for two
weeks, three days, forty-seven hours, and
fifty-eight minutes.
He realized at this point that, no matter
how hungry he got, no matter how long he went
without water, he would not die.
Somehow, in this place, his body kept going,
his heart ticked along, far past what should
have been his expiration date.
He retrieved a small picture of Anna from
his pocket, gazing at her face by the faint
glow of the red light.
Two months, four days, and three hours in,
he recorded a formal message:
"My name is…
Robert Scranton.
I am a former Head Researcher of Site…
120, a Foundation facility dedicated to studying
various reality-bending SCPs, for the purpose
of developing more advanced countermeasures
towards such threats.
For the last… red light, speak to me,
'Two months, eight days, sixteen hours'
What red light said.
I have been trapped in what I believe to be
an empty pocket dimension.
Alone.
Yeah… alone.
All alone.
I'm calling this place SCP…
I don't know, I can't remember where we are,
screw it.
I don't know what's happened in the past…
red light, please, again.
Two months, eight days, sixteen hours.
But…
no one else is around to argue, and at this
point…
I'm just talking into this control panel to
keep myself together.
I…
I need to keep a record.
There might be some poor chump in the future
who ends up like me, and… if this ever actually
makes it out… maybe, maybe I can help stop
that from happening.
That's all I have going for me right now,
and I really need something to go for, hahahaha…
…So, yeah, Robert…
Scranton…
documenting a new SCP for… future research
purposes.
That'll have to do.
Here we go!"
A few days later, he added to his informal
SCP log:
"I don't know if we could… contain wherever
I am.
It's… definitely not on Earth.
To be honest I don't know where it is.
I…
I think it has do something with the Stabilizer
prototype…
I'll explain that more later.
Okay… um… yeah, wherever I am, I don't
think it can be contained much as… created.
No, no, that's not the word I'm looking for.
Um… entered.
Yeah, entered is better.
I came into this place because of some really
bad reality-bending accident and… no, no,
Robert, don't be like that yet, you don't
know if there's no exit yet.
This place…
It's some sort of reality gap, I think.
It's dark.
Really dark.
As in, this little red light that shows my
words are actually being recorded is the only
visible light in this entire place.
I can't see my hands, and I can barely see
the control panel here.
I've had to basically use the light as a center,
and remember how many steps I take and in
which direction.
I haven't gone past a hundred yet.
I'm too…
I'm too scared to.
Heh.
I wonder if my hair is turning white, right
now?
I can't even see what color it is anymore.
Speaking of which, my head has been a bit
itchy recently.
If I don't concentrate on it, it's fine, but
I feel this… tingling all over my face.
I'm not sure why.
I… just discovered a new property of this
place.
All this time, I've been thinking I might
be walking on… some sort of… flat ground,
if you will.
I kept eye contact with little red as far
as I could see, and it seems I could walk
in a straight, flat path.
Jesus, my head is buzzing right now, I think
the adrenaline is still kicking…
But, if my hypothesis is correct, and this
really is some sort of reality… void, then
there shouldn't be anything to walk on.
Now that I think about, the whole time I've
been in here, it's felt like…
I'm walking, but I'm also swimming through
something.
It's like I'm walking through really thick
black gel.
There's enough tension to keep me on a…
"surface", but if I… imagine myself pressing
down hard enough, I can descend.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, I think…
I think I need to test this more, I'll be
back.
Two months, seventeen days, two hours.
Navigation is largely affected by… conscious
impulses to travel in a certain direction.
So, this definitely isn't a complete reality
gap, at least according to mine and Anna's
theories.
If-if it were I wouldn't have been able to
move at all, since space wouldn't have existed.
Holy shit, okay, okay, this makes a lot more
sense than it did before, great, great job,
Robert, you're getting there.
…Come to think of it, I should've realized
that sooner when I was able to move in a flat
plane to and from little red.
It also explains why I'm not dead from dehydration
or hunger yet, time barely passes in here.
Okay yeah, so, I stood right next to little
red, and went straight…
"down."
Okay, from here on out, imagine little red
as the origin of a 3D space.
I went straight…
down, right, yeah, and then… and then I
was then able to come back "up" to little
red again.
I've also been able to "fly" above red.
Movement in here is slow, like I said, gel
analogy, best I can describe it by."
As Robert became more familiar with his surroundings,
with the truth of where he found himself,
something became clear: Of all the things
in this new reality, he and his little red
light were the realest.
With time, they would begin to degrade, to
fall apart.
He had, in estimation, three years before
he would be gone for good.
He had to try and look for an end to this
place, a way out.
What did he have to lose?
As it turned out, what he had to lose was
himself.
He couldn't feel his legs anymore, couldn't
keep a grip on his own body.
He ran in one straight line for six months,
but found no edge, no end in sight.
He went down for eight months straight, and
never hit bottom.
His sole companion was the little red light,
and he continued to talk to it as if it could
ever answer.
His hands began to phase into each other,
his thumb came off without any pain, the integrity
of his form beginning to fade and warp.
No matter what happened to him, he could not
die.
His sanity began to crumble, his voice breaking
into uncontrollable sobs and hysterical laughter.
Whoever Robert Scranton had been, he was gone.
He was something else now, and who knew how
long that new thing would last?
For the next twenty-five years, Dr. Anna Lang
tried her best to put the thought of her lost
husband out of her head.
It almost worked some days, she almost forgot
that hole in her heart.
Then, one fateful day, Site-120 received a
deadly visitor.
SCP-106 reached through the back wall of her
lab, dripping its horrible rot all over the
floor.
It grabbed for her, its touch melting her
lab coat as she tore away from its toothless
grin, the singular focus in its milky eyes.
The old man chased her down, pushing past
a guard's bullets, tearing through everything
in its path.
She had done enough work on dimensional anomalies
to recognize one when she saw it, and this
was one of the most destructive she had ever
encountered.
When it finally caught her, it said one word:
"Red."
Then, another, one that made her eyes fill
with tears.
"Anna..."
Dr. Robert Scranton had found a way to escape
the dead-end prison he had fallen into, that
gap between the worlds.
All it had taken was giving up his humanity,
letting that world rearrange his atoms and
make him something monstrous, something that
destroyed all it touched.
He couldn't remember why he needed to find
Anna, how he had been separated from her for
so long, he could only remember that he wanted
her.
Wanted to be with her.
Wanted to touch her again, even as she screamed
and melted in his hands.
SCP-106 once was a man, just like any other
man.
What he is now shares the vague shape of the
human he used to be, the vaguest hints of
his memories, but that is where the similarities
end.
Like the rotting flesh of his body might suggest,
he is little more than a shambling corpse
with a ravenous appetite for violence.
Dr. Robert Scranton is dead, but he will never
rest.
Now go check out “SCP-106 - The Old Man
Tale - Until Death” and “SCP-106 - The
Old Man Origin Theories” for more on the
twisted and terrifying origins of SCP-106!